[Music]
spring is according to many a poem a
season of awakening the dreariness of
winter fades and the snow melts away to
reveal green earth animals emerge from
their slumber to fill the landscape with
their newly birthed young and then our
most idyllic imaginings the air carries
the sound of chirping birds and the
wondrous sense of daffodils and lilacs
and other fragrant flowers but nature is
a messy business spring isn't just
sunshine and greenery
it is also rain and mud and sometimes
puncturing through that floral perfume
are some sour notes maybe you've
wandered near a pond and caught a
strange hint of cucumber or maybe that
smell has deepened into something more
rancid like cod liver oil if you've
caught this unpleasant aroma you might
be experiencing spring in the micro
cosmos as the weather gets warmer lakes
and ponds begin to thaw affecting even
the tiniest residence the water around
them is still cool but it turns out
that's perfect because when spring comes
flowers aren't the only thing that bloom
Senora are found in fresh water
throughout the year joining together in
varied numbers to create spherical
colonies there are around 50 species
that are currently recognized from
around the world including in the Arctic
the only continent they have not been
found on yeah tase Antarctica but I mean
who can blame them these varied species
of Sonora are distinguished in part by
the structure of the complex silica
scales that adorn them we can't see
those scales with our microscopes but
scientists with electron microscopes are
able to analyze and categorize those
structures the scales are formed inside
specified vesicles and then molded into
shape by structures on the endoplasmic
reticulum and then they are arranged
into overlapping rows along the cell
surface but for all the order and
hardness implied by knowledge of their
scaly exterior if you take a wider view
Senora kind of look like marigolds
tumbling around in the wind like flowery
confetti each individual cell contains
two flagella and when they form a colony
those flagella are pointed outward and
the movement of the flagella of course
is what drives that jumbled swimming
[Music]
aside from their petal-like appearance
Senora also resemble marigolds because
of their distinctive yellow color these
organisms are crisis i'ts also known as
golden algae and on the first hearing
golden algae might sound a bit strange
algae are photosynthetic and most the
ones we've met in the micro cosmos are
green because of the pigmented
chlorophyll inside of their chloroplasts
well each senora cell has two
chloroplasts just two and those
chloroplasts do contain chlorophyll but
they are also colored with xanthophyll a
yellow brown accessory pigment that
helps the organism process light at
other wavelengths for photosynthesis the
xanthophyll ends up overshadowing the
green color of the chlorophyll and as
the colonies of sanera begin to
accumulate in a bloom you might see the
water they inhabit become brownish in
color as well
[Music]
Senora bloomin autumn as well as spring
but they're still present at low numbers
throughout the year and even when their
populations are more modest their scent
might still be apparent it only takes
about five to ten colonies in a
milliliter of water to produce a
cucumber smell so imagine what it's like
to be around a pond where the bloom is
in full swing even a single drop of
water might hold tens of thousands of
these colonies it's fortunate maybe then
that smellivision never took if it had
we would definitely be confronting you
right now with a very unpleasant fish
odor when Senora bloom the water around
them ends up filled with a cocktail of
alkenes aldehydes alcohols and ketones
that are likely the product of their
metabolism as the colonies accumulate so
to do these compounds and it's not like
all these chemicals have a particularly
bad aroma senora have been associated
with the release of beta aia known which
smells like violets and beta cichlid
citral which smells like tobacco these
sound like the fragrance notes you might
read on a nice expensive bottle of
perfume but of course that's not all
that's in the water Senora also produces
trans sis deca - for die enol a compound
whose name probably means nothing to you
until you happen upon its rancid smell
overshadowing all of the other aromas
and while this may not be the most
welcomed whiff when you are walking near
a pond the smell is handy if you happen
to be microbe hunting so much of
sampling is a mysterious subtle business
whether you're running a plankton net
through a lake or sticking your arm in a
mall aquarium tank you're searching for
the invisible which means that you have
to use environmental cues to figure out
what you might be collecting and you
usually will not know what microbes
you've gathered and
later when you get them under the
microscope but as the wise Gandalf once
said if in doubt Meriadoc always follow
your nose and the smell of signora may
not be pleasant but it is honest if you
want to observe many many signora then
you can track the smell to its bloom but
with blooms like this it can be
difficult to find other organisms in
your sample so you might end up using
the smell as more of a warning to stay
away signora of course are not the only
microorganisms to multiply in the blooms
and just as you can't understand the
entirety of the macrocosmos through any
one microbe you cannot understand algal
blooms by studying just one algae their
causes can vary from seasonal changes to
water pollution and their effects can
range as well some blooms are not
harmful while others can be toxic to
other organisms and damage local
ecosystems but at their core algal
blooms demonstrate the ingenuity of
microbes their talent for expansion
turning even the tiniest organisms on
our planet to a presence that none can
ignore thank you for coming on this
journey with us as we explore the unseen
world that surrounds us if you like this
show right now on the screen are all the
people you should be thanking they are
our patrons on patreon and if you would
like to join them you can head on over
to patreon comm slash journey to micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes James you can check out
Jam and germs on Instagram and if you
want to see some more from us with
beautiful footage and chill discussions
of the tiny inhabitants of our world we
are at youtube.com slash micro cosmos
you